[Music]
on this monday night
reopening the border ottawa finally
reveals plans to allow
fully vaccinated americans and other
international travelers to enter the
country
we make our decisions based on the
advice of our scientific experts and
the situation as it evolves in canada so
when will the united states open its
doors to canadians
clearing the air wildfire smoke is
choking alberta
i think we'll see this off and on for a
lot of the summer when will it let up
and where is it heading next plus what's
going on
with the greens the party tries to turn
the page on a turbulent chapter with a
federal election
looming
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin with big news on
the canadian border after nearly 16
months of pandemic restrictions the
federal
government says it's ready to start
opening the door to international
travelers
here are the dates as of august the 9th
fully vaccinated americans will be
allowed into canada for non-essential
reasons
without having to quarantine one month
later starting september the 7th
fully vaccinated travelers from most
other countries will also be allowed to
enter
children too young to be vaccinated can
visit too with some restrictions
and the government is doing away with
the hotel quarantine rules
but it all comes with a big caveat
canada's coveted 19 case load
must remain stable abigail beeman has
more on the changes in tonight's top
story
including whether the americans are
returning the favor
he's my favorite artist this gallery
owner is desperate to welcome
american tourists back to montreal but
says the news he can start to do so next
month
comes too late the season is almost over
and we are going to all die august 9
fully vaccinated americans will be
allowed to visit canada without
quarantining
everyone still needs a pre-arrival
negative pcr test result
but arrival or day one testing for fully
vaccinated travelers will now be done at
random
not for everyone unvaccinated children
won't have to quarantine
but there are vague rules banning group
settings like
school summer camps and no clarity on
visiting tourist attractions
we want to protect the upcoming school
year
children still are not able to be
vaccinated is it fail proof
absolutely not uh does the testing on
day one and eight reduce risk
substantially
yes i think it does define group setting
that has to be extremely clear
because that could mean four people 10
people 20 people it could mean 100
people i would
i don't know what that means since we
last spoke to mirei leija
on friday in connecticut tired of
waiting she drove her family to montreal
her two young boys
finally able to see their grandparents
at a distance while quarantining for now
i'll be back i'll definitely be back
with the kids that's
wonderful news for those unvaccinated
people allowed to come to canada the
government is dropping the hotel
quarantine altogether
you'd still need to quarantine somewhere
for 14 days
also in august five more airports will
accept international flights
edmonton winnipeg ottawa quebec city and
halifax
come september 7th the rules expand to
allow fully vaccinated people in other
countries to enter canada
but while the u.s and canada had moved
in lockstep for almost a year and a half
something changed i wouldn't look at it
through a reciprocal
intention they anticipate their curb
measures will likely be rolled over
canadians are still banned from crossing
the u.s land borders for discretionary
purposes
meaning cross-border shopping trips are
not part of the new rules
abigail beeman global news ottawa
though many of those border restrictions
are easing there are no changes to
canada's rules for travelers from
india today transport canada extended
the ban
on direct flights from that country
until at least august 21st
the government says the kovit 19
situation in india
is still too volatile and speaking of
arriving travelers it was a bittersweet
homecoming for hmcs halifax
after a crew member tested positive for
covid19
normally greeted by friends and family
today the sailors were met with
test kits the military says the case was
discovered yesterday as the ship was
heading home
after a six-month deployment in europe
they say the crew member is asymptomatic
and in isolation
and the crew will remain on board until
they receive negative test results
we've heard since the beginning of the
pandemic that it's safer to gather
outdoors but that option is now proving
difficult for people across much of
canada
heavy wildfire smoke is consuming skies
right across the country
today toronto ranked second in the world
for lowest air quality of any major city
just behind jakarta well this is what it
looks like from space
those are the great lakes down there
completely covered by smoke
with wildfires still raging in western
canada the situation could get worse
heather urix west reports the thick haze
of smoke in calgary
is impossible to ignore i just notice it
more
sore throat and in my eyes etc
it bothers the sinuses a little bit
because there's so much
smoke in the air the smoke from hundreds
of fires burning in bc
has moved east settling over alberta and
parts of saskatchewan
a province dealing with wildfire
problems of its own
this blaze near larage just one of 161
active fires in the province 26 are
considered out of control
quite frankly i think we'll see this off
and on for a lot of the summer we're
weeks ahead
in the wildfire season so while we will
get some
brief reprieves i think that this is
something that we need to anticipate for
a lot of our summer
that's difficult news for anyone dealing
with chronic lung disease
smoke contains fine particles that can
cause inflammation in the lungs when
inhaled
which can be especially dangerous for
those with conditions
like asthma or copd we've definitely had
an increased call rate especially over
the weekend here i've been working
just with people feeling like their
chests are getting a little bit tighter
they can't breathe that well
but even healthy lungs can be harmed by
air quality levels
so poor across most of alberta monday
health officials advised everyone to
avoid doing
any strenuous activities outside the
most important thing to do right now is
to stay out of the smoke
and there is little good news in the
forecast while smoky conditions are
expected to improve slightly for
southern alberta including calgary
for areas in northern alberta and out
east as far as ontario
air quality is expected to get worse
over the course of the week
as all this smoke moves across the
country heather urex west global news
calgary and there is no relief in sight
for firefighters across much of british
columbia with
more hot dry weather in the forecast
about 300 wildfires are burning across
the province
dozens of those are considered a threat
to life or property
and almost a third are burning in the
tinder dry kamloops region one of the
most concerning
the white rock lake fire forced the
evacuation of 13 more properties last
night
200 others are on evacuation alert
and a major wildfire in the united
states is once again
being linked to an american power
company
pacific gas and electric is reporting
that its equipment may have sparked the
dixie fire
that blaze burning in northern
california has now grown to more than 74
square kilometers
the company says a repairman spotted a
fire at the base of a tree last week
and it was leaning on a hydro pole with
blown fuses
the same company's equipment has been
linked to hundreds of california
wildfires in recent years
including the state's deadliest blaze
back in 2018.
there are now about 70 active large
fires burning
across the united states
the green party has called off a
non-confidence vote against its leader
anime paul the move comes after an
internal mediation process to try to
resolve what had become
a nasty internal struggle paul says the
experience has been one of the most
difficult in her life
and she considered packing it in it
should not be this difficult
for people of goodwill people with
experience
to offer it in service to their country
there are too many good people that have
found it impossible and i simply didn't
want to be one of them
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is following the story so
david does this finally bring an end to
the crisis within the green party
no jeff i don't think so for one thing
we have yet to see the two sitting green
mps
both from vancouver island elizabeth may
and paul manley
say anything in public in support of
anime paul
in i don't know more than a month now
now may it must be said
is recovering from knee surgery and
until that recovery is complete she
has been avoiding engaging in public
debate but here's the second thing jeff
the party's federal council still
refuses to pay for
any staff in paul's office there could
be a federal election in a month or two
and the leader of this major party has
no staff
in her office i tell you i have never
seen anything like this
well you mentioned the potential looming
election
expected in the fall so what do you
think are the ramifications
of this internal struggle within the
green party on a possible election
outcome
well a couple of things to think about
first more than a million canadians
voted green in 2019
won them three seats to compare three
million voted for the ndp
got him 24 seats now as we look to a
federal election potentially
later this summer there are certainly a
large number of voters who
i think are at least thinking about
voting green
but even if those greens don't win any
seats
they steal votes from other parties and
in that way green voters can have an
impact on individual races
and i can tell you that in the on the
east coast particularly in pei new
brunswick
federal liberals they were very worried
in 2019
that greens would eat into their support
and perhaps allow a conservative to win
on the west coast a weak green party
is probably good news for jug meat sings
ndp the ndp are looking to vault over
the block quebecois to become the third
biggest party
uh in the house of commons so for all of
those reasons
the decisions we've seen anime paul make
and this turmoil that does continue
within the green party
it could definitely have an impact on
the outcome of
any federal election that we might have
later this year jeff
david aiken reporting for us in ottawa
tonight thanks david
several first nations leaders in
manitoba are calling on that province's
premier and his minister for indigenous
reconciliation
to resign it follows their controversial
comments about canada's residential
school system
after the discovery of mass graves who
in their right mind
can go we found one thousand five
hundred and five
babies children murdered in these
schools
hidden and burned in the ground and in
the same breath say
but residential schools were a good
thing
minutes after being sworn in last week
manitoba's new indigenous reconciliation
minister
said those who ran residential schools
believed they were doing the right thing
he later apologized and earlier this
month premier brian pallister criticized
protesters who toppled statues of queen
victoria and queen elizabeth
during a walk to remember children who
died at residential schools
coming up combating islamophobia and
anti-muslim attacks
in canada we're crying out and saying we
are not okay
and and we want uh all levels of
government to come together and
to make muslim women feel safer in the
streets
next the urgent call to action in the
face of a rising number of hate crimes
welcome back there are growing calls for
canada to take concrete action to combat
a rise in racism and discrimination and
later this week the federal government
will host a national summit on
islamophobia cabinet ministers will hear
directly from muslim and jewish
community leaders
to help chart a new path forward and in
hopes that in tragedies like the one
last month in london ontario
never happen again mike trolley reports
on the street side lawn where four
members of the afzah family died in
london ontario
signs denouncing the alleged hate attack
sit as a reminder of what happened
there were rallies denouncing
islamophobia and hate
a televised funeral yet every day
there's been
something else in edmonton wadi rachmann
says
they've seen a rise in hate incidents as
pandemic restrictions have eased
our identity kids getting attacked
and that that's the immediate needs
that i think should be addressed in
advance of a national summit on
islamophobia this week
muslim leaders are doing just that the
reality
is that canada has suffered more mass
killings motivated by islamophobia in
the last five years
than any other country in the g7 to that
end
they've come up with 61 recommendations
to address islamophobia through all
levels of government
which includes a federal review of the
human rights act and a study into how
national security agencies
have failed to deal with white
supremacist groups the creation of hate
crime accountability units in every
province
and pass a strict municipal street
harassment bylaws
the time they say is now and muslim
leaders are imploring lawmakers
to understand that urgency and if folks
don't indicate that
i think it tells us something about you
know what is the level of commitment
vis-a-vis pure intentionality or
in terms of actually getting things done
beyond the muslim community experts who
monitor hate groups say
there should be greater urgency to make
change the center on hate bias and
extremism has recorded a three-fold
increase in the number of active hate
groups over the last five years
which in part can be attributed to
larger groups of neo-nazis and white
supremacists
splintering into factions and now our
typology it looks like
you know a giant spider web there are um
you know probably eight ten twelve
different elements to the movement now
in the wake of the london tragedy
commitments were made by politicians
across the country
to once and for all address hate will
those promises be kept
mike drolite global news toronto
still ahead we'll introduce you to
canada's flag bearers
at tokyo's olympic games
you're watching global national
[Music]
the countdown to tokyo is nearly
complete with athletes and olympic
organizers in japan getting set for the
games to begin
in less than a week well today the prime
minister announced miranda aim
and nathan hirayama will be canada's
flag bearers
for the opening ceremony on friday now
it's the first time in history that
canada has had two athletes marching
with the maple leaf
at the summer games here's crystal
gomencing
nathan hiroyama grew up watching the
olympics at 33 he's about to step onto
the world stage as one of canada's
flag bearers tokyo will be the first
games to feature a canadian men's rugby
team
having gone through that and put in the
work over the last five years to get
to get to tokyo here with with this
group of people is is really special and
um
something we're really excited about it
may be hiriamo's olympic debut but he'll
be able to lean on veteran support
during the opening ceremonies
this will be miranda aims fourth and
final olympics
the basketball star is already
dispensing valuable wisdom and
inspiration for young athletes
especially young girls whatever our your
strength
is um play that up to the best of your
ability
uh don't compare yourself to others stay
in your lane
and continue to to follow your dreams
making the olympics is a dream this one
has been on hold for a year but slowly
canadians
are making their way to japan 370
athletes will be taking part
the largest team canada since 1984.
what we have been experiencing is a
generosity
and an effort to make these games safe
and very successful
calling the game successful may come
down to how you measure it
japan's largest car maker and game
sponsor toyota
says its president and top officials
will not be attending the opening
ceremonies friday
it's also pulling all of its
olympic-related ads in japan
i need to emphasize that those partners
and companies
have been very supportive to talk to
anything they
are passionate
many people in japan fear the games
can't be held safely
and don't want them to go ahead at all
four athletes have already tested
positive for covid19 in tokyo
dozens of close contacts now face
heightened scrutiny
officials say this was always going to
happen
it's how quickly we identify them how
quickly the cases are taken away
quarantined and treated and looked after
and how quickly the contact
contacts are identified and put into
isolation canadians already in tokyo say
they feel
safe and they're taking all the
precautions possible
and they're ready to compete canadian
fans are united hoping
they'll be able to crystal commansing
global news
london canada is joining the u.s
and the uk blaming china for a major
cyber attack that targeted users of
microsoft exchange the hack compromised
four hundred thousand servers around the
world and infected
at least thirty thousand organizations
in the us
thousands more here in canada in a
statement today canada's ministers of
foreign affairs
national defense and public safety said
they are confident
chinese state-backed actors compromised
the exchange servers
to steal intellectual property and
personal information
china has previously denied the
allegations and that is global national
for this monday
i'm jeff semple tonight's year canada is
middle cove
on the avalon peninsula in newfoundland
and labrador
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna friesen we'll
be back here with you tomorrow
have a great night